how to create an app with no money so I
got a great question from my YouTube
viewers love you guys pantyhose Pam who
wrote in to say hello Evan I have a real
multimillion-pound app unfortunately
just an idea and it is unique at the
moment such an app hasn't been released
yet the problem is I can't write the
code for and it can't pay all the code
writers for the job what would you
suggest Thank You Pam great question and
usually when I make these videos I give
three suggestions for you can do for you
I really just have one and that's
partner-up
find somebody who loves programming just
as much as you love creating and
marketing stuff and work together
because if you don't have the funds to
hire somebody on board then the best bet
is that have somebody on your team who
is just as committed to this as you it's
hard to run a technology company when
you don't have a technology person in
the business because there's gonna be so
many issues that come up where you need
technical expertise and if you can't
afford to hire somebody then you have to
have somebody who's a partner in the
business and it's also great because you
have somebody who's committed to it just
like you are right if something crashes
at 3:00 in the morning your employees
not going to wake up and go to work but
your partner is and so it's finding that
right person what you need to do is
figure out what your skill sets are so
if you want to do the marketing and
promotion the branding of it that's what
you're really good at and you're this
awesome idea for an app you want the
people who love making apps who've
created great apps and I get people
write in to me all the time I've created
this great app but I don't know how to
market it I don't know how to brand and
I don't know how to promote it and get
the word to spread about it all I want
to do is create apps that's who you need
to partner with so I would go out and
find people in the industry write
whatever industry you're trying to
target if it's healthcare or sports or
children or whatever it is find people
who've created apps in that industry
that
our great app developers but haven't
done a great job marketing and partner
up with them and say hey I have this
very different app let's split it let's
work together on this you code it I've
got this great idea and I will go out
there and market it and together we can
build a great team that's you need to
find a partner I believe those are
watching like the video you can support
me by clicking on the link in the
description that's what helps keep these
videos going you can comment let me know
what you think leave a comment below and
click on my face subscribe to the
channel thank you so much I'll see you
soon